so
so
[Music]
foreign
so
so
so
[Applause]
[Applause]
happy nfl sunday and a happy halloween
everybody you just tapped into the br
betting squad ride live in the bleacher
report app presented by draftkings and
we got a very scary show for you today
my name is connor rogers alongside the
hoodie king the guy that you want to
stop by his house to not get candy but
he's given got all the good giveaways
today nfl jerseys tons of hoodies greg
how we feeling today
feeling good feeling generous and
feeling so generous in fact connor i
feel like uh giving out a hoodie now why
not i am in
the handy dandy ipad for the people
that's new to the show this is the
device that you get your hoodies on and
this is the device that i see your take
so get in the comments fill up those
comments with good takes and i'm giving
away hoodies like to z rod zero four
zero zero four he just simply commented
zack moss and guess what connor zack
moss is on my fantasy team so therefore
zma z-rod zero four you're walking away
with a hoodie it's it's as simple as
that it's it's that simple connor this
is a show where we bet anytime touchdown
scores that's what we want we want to
know who is getting in the end zone
chosen by you the squad on friday we
asked you on social we asked you in the
app who is going to find their way to
six here's the most popular picks you
sent us no surprises at the top derrick
henry did not score a touchdown running
or receiving last week which usually is
a good sign for this weekend alvin
kamara and joe mixon of course two other
running backs at the top stephon diggs
and josh allen it's been a nice
connection of course for the last two
years jamar chase the undisputed future
rookie of the year mike williams
hopefully that bye week gave his knee
some time to heal up and get right and
be the dominant force that he's been
early in the season and the target
monster of all target monsters with the
steelers in deontay johnson so a pretty
fun list we got today
greg what other treats do we have in
store for the people
i'm not only giving out hoodies today
connor we're just not giving away hoodie
but i'm giving away two nfl jersey uh
gift cards today one goes to the winning
lock legend and one goes to a lucky
commenter like
you so don't go anywhere stay tapped in
right here with me and connor get in the
comments and do what you do if you need
a jersey if you need a hoodie i need
gifts i need emojis but most importantly
most importantly i need winners only
please so fill those comments up y'all
all right we have four legendary picks
to show you you know the deal by now the
winner takes home the jersey the winner
takes home the title of squad ride
leader and of course greg is going to
work his magic and boost up that anytime
touchdown score for drafting so you want
to stick around our first pitch comes
from josh stotz 28. josh tell us who's
scoring a touchdown today
welcome to the special halloween be our
betting anytime touchdown scorer our
selections for the day are jamar chase
derek henry
tyreek hill cooper cub and josh helping
me make my pick today is my little
friend here who holds the bowl of wisdom
i'm gonna crumble all these selections
up and the bowl of wisdom will do the
rest
and the pick is
derrick henry
so the basement of saw going with
derrick henry at minus
165 and we got the first challenge of
the day here the first decision that's
not going to be up to me it's not going
to gray it's moving to the comments so
get ready for this one here's our second
pitch from mike o.c
[Music]
[Music]
all right i'm already freaked out
already you heard our first two pitches
we got the clown legend we got the
stranger things vibes going on greg do
you like either of these here
uh connor before i get in here uh what i
need everybody to do is get in the
comments
tell me if you're riding with the clown
legend or the stranger things legend
i'll give both of these videos at a for
effort i'll give it both of these videos
a forever very creative uh shout out to
them they're spooky i mean shout out to
them for for for taking the the the
putting in the effort basically but uh i
need to talk about these pics connor
gotta talk about these pics we got
derrick henry josh allen love the derek
henry play you threw out a stat that's
saying you know when he don't score he
usually scores again but it's minus
165. i don't really like that i like
this josh allen plus 100 though because
you know what we can do here connor we
can change this plus 100 boost it up
some more and it's a it's a good bet
it's a fair bet so i think i want to
lean josh allen which way are you
leaning connor i'm rolling with you greg
i love what your thought process is
right i think both you and i feel great
about derek henry getting in the end
zone this week but at what cost what
money is there right we're looking at
the odds here josh allen has the
dolphins they're favored by two
touchdowns we know what josh allen can
do on the ground as a runner he is their
red zone running offensive threat plus
100 i want to see what you can boost
that up to so i'm rolling with josh
allen how are the comments feeling right
now about both of these
uh connor i am in the comments right now
and um
early it's early i'm seeing a lot of
derek henry seeing a lot of derek henry
i got not jaylen waddle uh with the
derek henry gif i'll show you guys there
it is my boy derek henry at alabama with
the gift uh
i got mo dz derek henry two touchdowns
two touchdowns winners only shout out to
you mo deezy uh the two people that i
mentioned you're walking away with a
hoodie
connor do not be afraid because uh josh
allen is getting some love too monks in
midfield monks and misfits says josh
allen uh
actually we're going to call it we're
going to call it with this next one
we're going to call it with this next
one
i got t gibson saying t gibson saying
josh allen so connor
it appears
the people have spoken it's actually
back and forth in the comments but i'm
going off the last comment that i just
read it appears people have spoken we
are rocking with the stranger things
legend and josh allen to move on to the
next round a tight round one but that
belongs to mike oc we got two spooky
challengers remaining on to round two
let's get into it our next pitch comes
from stager 12. who you got
[Music]
jamar chase i love that pick love the
halloween decor from stager all right
the halloween party legend taking on the
stranger things
greg this is a little bit tighter both
plus money we love that jamar chase has
got the jets big time bengal favorites
josh allen's got the dolphins big time
bill's favorites i think both of these
guys might score today which way are you
leaning
connor this one's tough man this one is
tough um
i'm gonna ask the people you guys get in
the comments and let me know are we
rocking with the holly uh not the
hollywood but the halloween party
legend it might be hollywood you know
jamar chase he likes to dance a little
bit you know what i'm saying uh but are
we walking with the halloween party
legend or is it the stranger things
legend you guys let me know get in the
comments connor i'm going to keep this
one simple i'm going to keep this one
short and sweet uh jamar chase taking on
those new york jets uh that jets
secondary
we know how that goes for the new york
jets but uh
jamar chase been bawling man he's hot
right now i'm gonna ride jamar chase
he's sitting at plus 110 you know
without what we us here on the draft uh
on the draftkings sports book show which
is called the squad right you know what
we can do we boost those odds for you
guys uh so i might want to ride with
jamar chase connor which way are you
thinking i'm going with jamar chase as
well special season for jamar there's
been weeks he gets in the end zone twice
i mean this to me joe burrow to chase is
the new matt ryan to julio i think he's
special i also like the halloween vibes
over there as well so i'm rolling with
you marc chase can we push the people to
do the same greg how are they feeling
let me ask them let me out i already
asked them but let me get into the
comments and see yup we pushed them
connor
it's a runaway it's a runaway
chase chase chase stay chase i got
brandon bostrom brandon brostrom jamar
chase is a lock no doubt i got matt
dodger in the comments going with jamar
chase shout out to you matt dodger josh
goats jamar chase shout out to you josh
goats uh jt envy jt for mvp zero chase
is a lock that's four hoodies right
there that i just gave out everybody
that i mentioned you were walking away
with hoodie
connor
it appears the holly the halloween party
legend i don't know why i keep calling
it hollywood i think jamar chase is
gonna have a hollywood day today i think
he's gonna i think he's gonna put on the
show so that's
it's the vibes it's the vibes jamar
chase is gonna put on the show today and
we're rocking with him he's moving on to
the next round let's go the final round
all right second round belongs to
stager12 like i said though this is
winner takes all this is to take home
the jersey just take home the squad ride
leader title on halloween a little
different a little extra special a
little extra something all right let's
get into it next up familiar face riley
sorbo let's see what you got for us
today riley
what's up squad ride we're out here
we're trying to make some picks
we're gonna go trick-or-treating we're
gonna we're gonna see if anyone has
any idea who might score
a touchdown tomorrow
let's see if we can uh
figure this out
oh hi
um
hey i'm out here trick-or-treating i
know it's a day early
you may not even have candy but uh
i was i was wondering if you may have an
idea who might score a touchdown
tomorrow
in the nfl
kamara alvin kamara okay you guys heard
it alvin kamara lock it in thank you so
much have a great day
there we go
now that is a bold move
trick-or-treating a day early and asking
for the lock of the week with no
hesitation there either he said kamara
right away this is a great finale here
greg i'm looking at that plus money
which way are you feeling here chase or
camara
a uh get in the comments what i need
everybody to do because this one's hard
conor this one this one's tough alvin
kamara you know he he is the engine for
that saints offense jamar chase he's
been hot he has been hot uh so get in
the comments and let me know who we
should ride with is it the halloween
party legend or is it the trick or treat
legend
connor
love the take by my guy
riley loved the take by my guy riley but
uh
jamar chase is plus 110. abu kumar is
sitting at minus 150 i mean you know we
can boost those odds up from -150 but we
can boost those odds even more
for this plus 110 so i'm leaving jamar
chase man and he's taking on the jets
like come on bro this is the no-brainer
finale to me here greg where i am i am
demanding the comments to go with jamar
chase the book is out on the saints
every other team knows it's alvin kamara
all day they're going to try to take him
away whoever every single week whoever
is playing the saints is going to try to
take away alvin kamara with jamar chase
i think the jets can put they could
bracket him for all matters and it's not
gonna stop him there's no stopping him
like you said look at the odds here
that's the ultimate decider here i wanna
see what you can get those jamar chase
odds up to did we push the people far
enough is this over
it might be conor it might be the
comments are jumping i got rob powell 15
chaser
chaser uh shouts out to you rob powell
15. i got irvin sanchez saying chasey
chasey shout out to you irvin sanchez
you are walking away with it both you
guys are walking with i guess they're
just making up nicknames for my guy
jamar chase in the comments uh
here we here we go uh chasing ghost td
he just appears in the end zone shout
out to ud blake13 love the take uh it's
a runaway connor d butler 5 says chase
for president shout out to ud butler 5
maybe chase uh might be for president
and i got one more lee ross garza says
chase has three touchdowns today against
the jets connor
whoo that might be
that
that will be a day if he uh does that so
uh connor
i think it's very apparent
i think it is very apparent that people
have spoken we are riding with the
halloween party legend
and stager 12 and jamar chase as the
squad ride of this week let's pull up
the graphics so i can show you guys how
we are gonna boost those odds for you
guys look at this magic jamar chase plus
110 poof
there it goes it went up it went up
from
110 to 175 shout out to our friends over
at draftkings they're boosting these
odds for us check out br betting socials
for links to the odds boost send us your
screenshots of your bets send us your
videos and your celebration
but remember please remember
we want winners and winners only please
connor that's right my man all right
we're not done got more locks to talk
you got hoodies to give away still one
more jersey to give away in the spirit
of halloween and hang out in the vr
betting community stream in the br app
you know we asked you in the spirit of
the holiday a little question in the
comments there
for scary terry how many receiving yards
for scary terry against those broncos
this week we picked two of our favorite
comments to show you so let's waste no
time greg let's take a look how the
people feel about scary terry this week
yes sir connor what i need the people
that are watching too what i need you
guys to do is get in the comments and
tell me which of these is the better
take i'm going to give a hoodie to
whoever
you guys choose so let's take a look at
the first comment from king greek easy
king greasy says
131 yards for scary terry with a couple
emojis at the end connor
how are you feeling about this take
right here 130 131 for scary terry well
i think we found scary terry's biggest
fan the line is at 67 and a half
receiving yards so this man went and
doubled that right out of the gate
this is a little rich for me here greg
i'm gonna be honest we and it's not
scary terry's fault he's going up
against a really good broncos secondary
they got corners his quarterback
situation has just not been what we
expected of course since ryan
fitzpatrick got hurt so
is the next comment going to be a little
bit more pessimistic or are we just
rolling the good scary terry vibes here
hey let's let's see let's see the next
comment is from
k
miz123 and uh connor k miss says seven
catches for 127
and a td all in a losing effort wow that
is big a losing effort to the broncos
all right conor the first one said 131
yards
now we're talking 127. did that
change your mind a little bit man it's
gonna get to 127. i'm considering the
over a 67 and a half i didn't say double
it out here this is great i think these
i think they like the same game parlay
option where you could really bump up
the totals for each player uh these are
both nuts to me greg and i respect it
and i hope they're right and i hope we
look foolish
do people agree i mean is this just a
scary terry uh fan base today
a uh a shout out to moe deezy he says
scary terry over 67 and a half sure he
could have put him to sleep he fit to
put him to sleep
that's a lot uh
hey anything's possible though you never
know connor anything is possible um
great great great player i got joe
teach27 said six receptions
57 yards in the td for scary terry shout
out to you joe teach um
here we go uh terry about to go off
d-boy 22 says terry is about to go off
everybody that i mentioned you guys are
walking away with the hoodie also king
greasy
king greasy is walking away with a
hoodie because uh
i just wanted to pick him why not keen
greasy i like your take better to what
131. all right so we go from laughing at
some comments now people can laugh at us
because it's boldest bets of the week
time this is where we get crazy this is
where we sprinkle some money on some big
time long shots greg tell the people
what we need from them for our boldest
bets time
connor
what i need the people to do is get in
the comments and tell me if they're
riding with me or if they're riding with
you
uh
yeah you guys just let us know connor's
been hot he's hit a couple of these
before so let us know if you're riding
with me through ron mcconnell connor
talk to the people who you got greg i'm
looking at your niners for some help on
the boldest bets and looking for the
juice to get in the end zone kyle use
check on the niners only one touchdown
we need here that's it this is a two
touchdown three touchdown bet one
touchdown for the juice to get loose at
plus 450
feeling okay about this i think they are
going to put up a lot of points against
the bears who are without khalil mack
where are you at with your boldest bet
this week
first off i just want to say i love love
your pick love your pick
jimmy loves to check down yeah love the
check down to his running backs and the
full backs so you have a good play you
have a good pick there connor uh let me
hop in here we've been talking jamar
chase all
day it seems like we've been talking
about gibberish pull up the graphics so
i could show the people there it is
jamar chase
to get 150 plus receiving yards and a
touchdown against those new york jets
you can do it i like
i like i like my chances here he's been
absolutely hot uh this season uh he has
a connection with joe burrow
so i can see this happening and look at
the odds plus 600 bro i'm rolling the
dice here connor i love those odds this
is a fun one we are on jamar chase today
for halloween i love that one we got to
let the people decide who they're riding
with and i know you still have a jersey
to give away before we get out of here
today
yes yes yes sir yes sir let me get into
these comments let me get into these
comments uh
here we go let me get into these
comments man they're moving they are
moving riding with connor all day he
don't miss shout out to josh goats uh
respect shout out to josh goats ak 47
big blue says both of you got good picks
shout out to you ak-47 loving the vibes
uh
you're walking away with a hoodie
connor did you say something about a
jersey
something about a jersey man you still
got one more jersey it's halloween you
want to stop at greg's place no candy no
coconut candy you're getting the good
stuff
let me hop in here man let me hop in
here connor you are getting love in the
comments you are getting love i got go
white socks go white sox says connor
doesn't miss let's get it baby connor
doesn't miss and guess what go white sox
you didn't miss on this jersey there we
go we're walking away with a jersey for
the love that you showed to my guy
connor connor rogers at that i love it
greg good vibes on the halloween show
today i think everybody's in a really
really good good mood for some winners
today before we get out of here we got
something special we got something
special it's the trick or treat special
from giraffe kings of course our friends
over there hooking us up with a special
halloween odds booth odds moose mania
mark chase touchdown get those wagers in
long shots get those wagers in scary
terry craziness put them in have some
fun trick or treat betting style special
here opt in on draftkings and you'll
randomly get one of two futures boosted
are you ready for this greg the treat
future yes sir cardinals ravens packers
chargers titans
chiefs to make the playoffs all of them
they got to make the playoffs
all right now the trick wow future
giants dolphins jags texans jets or
lions you just need one of them to make
the playoffs not a good pool of teams
sorry whichever one's randomly selected
you get boosted by a plus 100 greg i
drew the trick option
not that thrilled about it would you bet
on it do you think any of those sorry
teams make the playoffs
connor i am not
touching those sorry no thanks i'm
leaving
i'm leaving that i'm leaving that no no
i'm leaving that where it is and i might
touch the treat option i might touch the
tree with uh
all of the teams to make the playoffs
only one i'm kind of skeptical about is
the los angeles chargers but uh those
other teams should make the playoffs all
right get on draftkings and see if you
get a trick or retreat it seems like you
definitely want that treat let us know
on social if you're riding with any of
those
happy halloween everyone good luck with
your wagers today it's been a lot of fun
it's always a lot of fun these holiday
themes are the best congrats to our
hoodie and jersey winners you know the
deal by now if you won br betting is
gonna dm you in the next 24 hours
they're gonna take care of you have no
fear thanks to everyone that commented a
lot of love today we really appreciate
that thanks for the lock
josh stotz mike oc stager riley great
videos bringing that halloween spirit
enjoy your sunday everybody drop your
real whoa
but i had to give the people i have to
give the people what they want here we
go i got lee rose larose garza larose
garza says
lock he says lock just for saying vlog
brother you're getting you're in why not
here we go back into the comments d
blake 13 says oh chase nc oh chasen c
shout out to you d blake you're walking
away i got one more in me connor goat
garden says happy halloween happy
halloween everybody uh go garden you
were walking away with a hoodie that's
right everyone make sure you follow br
bang on ig stories all day greg is
always holding it down with the good
stuff
alongside greg my name is connor rogers
see you next week same time same place
[Music]
[Music]
you